what's up guys my name is shano welcome
back to the Cherno podcast the podcast
that we do every now and then when we
have a special guest in town which we do
today his name is baji hello and he'll
be talking about why he's making the
switch from Unity to Hazel exactly yeah
today I've decided this is it right now
after after seeing Studio Journal it's
it's been a life-changing experience
so bhaji for those of you who don't know
who you are you have a YouTube channel
uh what do you do
basically just make stupid games make
videos on the games that's about it I
mean uh we are working on a like a
proper one now which is uh called gopogo
it's like uh the pitch we're using is
it's like Mario Kart and pogo sticks you
play as these animals lots of like
ragdoll physics really goofy and that
one we're actually planning to turn into
like a fully fledged like
sell it all that stuff yeah cool do you
have any kind of timeline for that or is
it just kind of rolling around we're
trying not to like
say anything because we keep promising
yeah and then we keep extending so we
don't want to say exactly one but but it
shouldn't be it should it's definitely
going to be this year like at some point
oh okay cool yeah that's pretty quick
when did you start working on it
um it's been like it's been a weird
development because we started on on it
in like June but that was really early
prototyping just like we basically had
the idea for the pogo stick so it was
you move your cursor around or like your
mouse around and you lean in the
direction that you're kind of In Motion
right so if you're moving your mouse to
the left the pogo stick starts to lean
towards the left and that was the idea
we had for the movement originally and
so that it was we prototyped that in
like June and then we were like this is
cool we could do something with this and
then slowly we started to build it up
um we had like my business partner
Timothy was like working on it on you
know just the prototype in the next few
months like uh you know on the side and
then in November we were like let's
actually do this let's make a full thing
and yeah so that's kind of cool since
then did that idea come out of like a
game Jam or was that just prototyping
like for fun
I can't remember it's quite an
interesting idea like pogo sticks like
yeah but progress takes that's like that
stick that you you put your feet on like
little platforms to jump on it right
yeah I think I've have have you have you
actually used one in real life I bought
one for a video for a bit okay after
this where I like went to try and then
just smacked into my fridge yeah like
I'm just like Curious like they're
really hard I have yeah
yeah really okay they're difficult
because I remember I just remember this
one memory from my childhood of some
like one of the kids on the street had
one lying around and
that's all I like when I hear pogo stick
I just that little memory is just in my
mind and that's it but yeah because I
feel like they're not that popular these
days no kids these days no
so when did you start like your Game Dev
journey in general and what did you
start with
um was it 2018 2019 uh
think it was the end of the beginning of
2019.
um so at the time I was like I was still
in high school I was like basically just
coming home and playing video games all
the time and I was like I kind of wanted
to do something but something productive
but I didn't know what and then I was
like Game Dev why not yeah and so I
started like searching YouTube whatever
came across Blackthorn prod
um and he just released like a udemy
course which was like
I think it was like a 2d
uh it was like an endless Runner but you
were like there was meteorites falling
down and you were on a static screen you
had to move left and right and Dodge
them oh yeah
um so I made I made a game called knife
storm which was just the same thing but
with knives dropping
um in like two days uh that was the
first ever game first ever game I TR I
dabbled like when I was like immunity
yeah yeah I I tried like game maker
years before but like to the you know
like opening up a YouTube tutorial and
then just following it word for word and
then giving up so it wasn't like a big
part up until then yeah and then I did
that in two days
um obviously I had no idea what I was
doing like just basically copying the
code and then like you know trying to
figure some stuff out on my own uh and
then I was like all right it's time to
make a real game I'm good enough now
yeah so I then started on a game called
chicken slapper which is based on
there's like a
the idea that if you slap a chicken how
many times you have to slap a chicken to
cook it to cook it yeah so I was like
that would make a cool clicker that was
like someone on YouTube made that that
machine right oh the machine yeah I
think it's always a machine that just
rotates and slaps the chicken yeah I did
a thing is it I think he's Australia
yeah he's Australian yeah yeah
Jamie pull that up
no it was uh you made a game like that
yeah it was just a clicker game on
mobile and then I I slapped it what
would you call it chicken chicken
who is why am I typing simulator yes
this guy this was I cooked a chicken by
slapping it he did it
Paris
oh sponsored by hello Friday yeah cut
this bit out
yeah okay so you made a game like that
yeah so I made that and then I put it on
mobile and told all my friends to
download at school or whatever yeah
right it that was cool like actually
getting feedback see that's like to be
honest like one of the most annoying
things of my career and I guess making
kind of games more or less usually from
scratch is the the fact that like
at no point was I able to just quickly
release a game on mobile I mean mind you
like when I made my first game well my
first ever game was probably 2006 but my
first kind of more or less game when I
knew what I was doing and could program
and stuff was like in 2012 right and
like I guess Mobile gaming wasn't like
that big then I want to remember like
Angry Birds and stuff was around maybe
some weird like Call of Duty first
person clones that no one ever actually
played because it was just terrible but
like yeah I was never able to really
just export a game to run on mobile and
I feel like that's really cool like
these days I guess with engines like
Unity where you can just be like I can
get everyone in my year level easily to
play it I mean we had we all had laptops
though so I guess it's not that big of a
difference like getting someone to
download and play a game on a laptop
versus mobile but it's just cool how
it's like so much more accessible now
yeah exactly 100 so yeah I mean that's I
release that and then kind of moved on
and just the next year I was kind of
just like dabbling and trying to make
stuff but not finishing anything just
like you know trying to build up my
skills or whatever yeah uh and then
covid happened and then all of a sudden
I had nothing to do
so it's a blessing in disguise it really
was I and I remember thinking at the
time I was like I'm gonna I'm gonna look
back on covid so like fondly just
because of you know like it gave me the
time to change your life yeah yeah it
gave me the time to just
do this all the time yeah and so it was
it was the next like well how long was
covered like probably six seven months
of just grinding away yeah and uh and
what were you like what were you doing
to better your skills there we're just
repeatedly making like it was splashing
out ideas or that was a weird time docs
tutorials it was weird because that was
like the time where I wanted to try all
this technology so I wasn't just doing
Unity like during that like because I
kind of wasn't sure whether I wanted to
go into games or like typical
programming so at that point I was
trying everything I was doing like all
different types of programming like
trying like sfml sdl just trying all
these different Technologies but I can't
remember if I actually released a game
towards the end of that or a during
lockdown I don't think I did
maybe a couple of hdio games oh that was
probably when you made that c plus
Asteroids game for your channel yeah
no that was that was December that year
but that's that's interesting because
that's kind of where you were dabbling
around in different yeah Technologies
around there yeah so then I made my
YouTube channel at the end of that okay
um and that's kind of yeah I I'd made
the Astros game yep and then that kind
of didn't do that well at first but then
like three months later it just went
and that was the video that kicked off
and then since then I've kind of just
been doing Unity stuff um and focused on
the YouTube channel yeah because I feel
like interestingly enough because uh you
know I release a lot of videos I guess
with C plus in the title and then that
video has C plus in the title that was
probably the first video of yours I
found even though I probably found it
like a few years after you released yeah
yeah but because I found because the
algorithm showed me that video because
it thought I was interested in C plus
plus then I found like the rest of your
videos as well yeah got it it's nice to
in a way dabbling in different
Technologies is actually really good
marketing yeah yeah I mean they're all
similar like yeah because the thing is
with my videos as well is I try not to
make them too technical I did back then
yeah but now it's like there's hardly
ever any code on the screen or anything
like that I've started doing that like
with devlogs as well yeah but possibly
for a different reason why did you I
just appealed to a broader audience well
I saw what was like like Danny was doing
and it was kind of like
okay yeah I can try and appeal to every
game developer in every programmer
whatever
but the stuff that I was doing it was
like I want I want people to play these
games like there's a huge audience of
Gamers out there right and if I want
them to watch this video then I can't be
going into like why time.del time works
and all this stuff so it was like it was
kind of just trying to make it
accessible to like a wider audience of
people who would actually be interested
in playing the games yeah so that's
that's kind of the reason yeah what
about you right so I so basically what
you're saying is you in a way it's
almost like
if you made a video that would appeal to
the people who would want to play the
game rather than necessarily developers
who would want to recreate what you've
done yeah that's that's a smart way the
thing is as well is like when like a
trailer it's almost like you'd like your
marketing yeah I guess for the game
that's 100 what it was yeah like when I
was younger like I used to just watch
game like Sebastian leg and stuff yeah
even though I knew nothing about it
because it interested me so it was kind
of like how do I take that and make it
even more accessible right yeah because
there are like a lot of people who play
video games are interested in how
they're made yeah they're just not
necessarily interested to the point that
they're gonna boot up yeah so it's that
that audience like how do you get them
to watch that's kind of where I went
like the reason that I decided to do
that yeah yeah now I am the reason why I
kind of switched from making it more uh
technical is just because it was it was
very overwhelming to try like because in
the beginning you know Hazel was uh
pretty simple and so if I added
something I could kind of roughly cover
all the bass of that implementation but
like now if I'm like you know if I've
been working on
uh you know
you know the renderer like because I've
been rewriting the renderer and that's
been like
the last four months and maybe like a
solid six weeks of work within those
four months like
if I was to compress that down to a
YouTube video like I feel like there is
zero value in that because what would I
how would I first of all presenting that
much technical information in a in a way
that would actually help people that's
really long form content like it's just
physically not possible for me to be
like let's do this quickly like I mean
look at like GDC talks for example yeah
or like um you know some kind of like
games conference even like CPP con or
something or C graph for graphic stuff
like you get a one-hour talk
and that's kind of the high level
overview of how they did that you know
and that's a one hour talk and that's a
talk they've obviously prepared really
well
like if I was to make a video being like
this is the new renderer it would be
really long which immediately makes it
not that suitable for YouTube right but
also that wouldn't even be like too deep
so what I've kind of switched to doing
is being like all right well
I and also I just feel like maybe 10 to
20 maybe even less of people would
actually be like yeah I want to know the
full details of this most of the people
who watch Hazel like devlogs I think
they just want to be like what have you
guys been doing what have you guys been
up to yeah you know like show us some
cool stuff basically and so it's I feel
like it's much better for me to make a
10 to 15 minute video that just kind of
is like check this out I did this this
is roughly how I did it this was the
journey the story that's kind of
interesting and then here's the end
result right it's a lot faster now yeah
or it has these new flashy features and
so what I've kind of started doing is
I've what I want to start doing is
making
um basically these kind of long-form
videos for patreon where it's like you
know I don't have to worry about the
YouTube algorithm I can just hit record
like explain everything at my own pace
it can be really chill and I can explain
all the details yeah and you know those
people who really want to watch that
like it's like five bucks a month for
that tier to get access to it but then
you get that almost educational kind of
you know deep content but then I don't
have to like sacrifice the performance
of my YouTube channel for that because
that's also difficult you know because
what what can happen a lot is if I have
videos that are kind of
bipolar meaning like you know some
videos do really well some videos do
really badly the problem is that a lot
of like potential sponsors will look at
that and they'll be like all right
what's the average view count of the
last 10 videos yeah and then like I have
to explain to them that like all my
managers have to explain to them that
like well yeah but we're not gonna put
your sponsored section on a video that's
going to do badly but then they don't
quite buy that or maybe they're not
willing to commit that makes makes sense
you know I understand that but that also
means that like you know
it kind of hurts the kind of business
before because they don't understand as
well as you do like what does well yeah
of course so you know you can take a
tactical decision to release a certain
video that you think's maybe not going
to do as well but would provide a lot of
value to subscribers and then like you
knew that was the case right before but
they don't they don't see that side of
it right so it's yeah no well yeah and
of course they're they're not they might
not be willing to do like a whole bunch
of research or take a risk on this and I
understand that but it's also kind of
like it's funny because it's like
if I put a long form video about hazel
out it hurts Hazel because obviously
like you know the money from
sponsorships gets reinvested back into
Hazel yeah so it's like if I actually
share more about hazel yeah then that
means that sponsors are less likely to
commit you know larger sums of money
which means that we can't fund Hazel
like we can't use that to fund Hazel as
well basically and create more
opportunities for Hazel and so like you
know if there's a way to kind of shift
that around because that's also kind of
one of the most annoying things I think
is that like even though Hazel is like
the product we're building there's the
whole YouTube side of the business and
that's like something I'm still kind of
trying to maneuver yeah but it also
means that yeah like there are some
concessions that have to be made but I'm
certainly finding ways you know like the
patreon Deep dive videos that I think
will be helpful you know for people who
really want that content yeah 100 I
agree because it's also like the way I
said it's also I'm a minority you know
anytime I put up an educational series
on YouTube like the ray tracing series
more recently like they always get less
views than just videos of maybe like hey
I did this you know or here's a oh
really reaction yep because I think that
more views would come from search for
that yeah yeah but the YouTube algorithm
doesn't spread it as well because also
the the average view duration is a lot
lower for those videos okay because like
you know those aren't videos you just
watch for fun I mean I'm sure some
people do but it's more or less like
most people would have to sit down and
follow along with that right and so if
they're just on their phones you know
just Doom scrolling and they come across
that video it's obviously not going to
engage them right and so that hurts the
stats yeah that's what you're saying
yeah
that's interesting
so
with something like the C plus plus
series then I'm guessing that that does
well that does well through search
yeah that does well for everything oh
really um yeah even though the average
view duration is Tiny which is really
interesting like I think it's still like
usually around 20 of the video okay
um but I don't yeah I just think that
maybe it's the constant hammering of
search that propels it and so maybe the
algorithm is like yeah because not no
other videos would really be popping up
in search results that often you know
but plus ones do like if you search C
plus plus I reckon oh no of course yeah
yeah I think I'm pretty sure I'm I'm
definitely on the on the table I mean
yeah Jamie get that get that going
but yeah like even um
even like C plus plus tutorial
definitely
there you are that playlist is third not
bad and then first video
search like C plus plus tutorial it's a
while down uh
no not even close
about your playlists they're pretty old
maybe that's what's why as well yeah
yeah
um
I yeah I but but I do think like it but
Tim actually bring up that engineer tab
search for Staples pointers or something
like kindness more specific because C
plus plus tutorial that's a good point I
don't have and people probably don't
search for that unless they want to
start
if you type in like Staples yeah yeah
the amount of times I've watched your
header file video when I've gone back to
work with C plus plus that's hello
actually
yeah maybe because it's old my head is
probably first I think yeah I think I
called it header files there
there it is all right well this has been
fun
I think maybe it's because the search
results bring in views
um then that way the algorithm also kind
of spreads it but for other videos like
about hazel you know that obviously will
get way less views from search results
and so if that doesn't
like organically do well just from
related videos then it's probably less
likely to be kind of promoted
Tim has acquired us a selection of
drinks by the way yeah we've got like
some kombucha and this like think feel
do better nootropics thing
so shout out to Tim he's our Jamie for
this podcast everyone needs a Jamie for
a podcast so wait this is orange mango
just like popular in Australia
I've never heard about I I never heard
of it before Tim
Tim just wanted to like love him to have
a year ago like let him down 50 50. yeah
yeah it's an alternative for energy
drinks it's like a healthy alternative
okay it tastes good yeah we've got like
healthy and Alternatives energy drinks
and I guess soft drinks in a way because
it's kombucha but kombucha is great yeah
so what is kombucha I drink kombucha I'm
talking about this
oh yeah you haven't tried one have you
no ever yeah you should no get on that
we should probably explain like why
we're in the same room oh yeah all right
yeah how did this come about yeah so I'm
in Australia so that's where we are
right now I'm in the UK yeah
no so uh yeah I'm just visiting and uh
we decided this this was this needed to
happen
it's been it's been years in the making
yeah
no I just um yeah you just like tweeted
being upside down yeah I think and I'm
actually 90 sure you can't look this up
for me but I'm 90 sure I don't follow
you you
um oh I can look that up yeah
the thing is I haven't needed to because
your tweets show up on my timeline
anyway
yeah I'm pretty annoying on Twitter to
be honest like oh yeah I'm oh I am so
like I'm never on Twitter that's the
thing though I Instagram I use a lot
you're not following me yeah I'm so
offended let's fix that yeah we're not
carrying on this podcast until I see
that that follows technical difficulties
um but yeah it's so weird I see your
tweets anyway yeah okay now I'm fine
um and so I saw that one of yeah you
being upside down you're in Australia
and then I just like replied and I was
like if you're in Melbourne let me know
and uh here we are so yeah there we go
the channel followed you back
cool this is good
computer
you get the passion for everyone
yeah yeah no I'm trying the passion for
you almost right now I like the passion
fruit one it's pretty good
um all right so what are we talking
about we're talking about yeah YouTube
and stuff basically yeah YouTube and
yeah okay so like just around December
2020 it was your first video and what
like why did you so you said that you
basically started making those videos
well no it's kind of promote the games
basically it's kind of a lie because I
did I did make a few videos okay but
then so I made this what was the first
first like not your current Channel but
like did you ever have a channel yeah
yeah no like I was that kid I I tried
everything like I was I've been doing
YouTube since like I can long as as long
as I can remember like yeah setting up
my Samsung Galaxy Tab 2 aimed at the
screen playing Minecraft kind of nice
like I've done loads nothing you're
recording your screen like from a camera
yeah that was that was yeah
there was that and then the only like
time that I ever got anywhere with it
was um
I did like a some fortnite stuff at one
point okay they added like a big piano
into the game you could jump on it yeah
and like I showed how you could make a
song with that
and then that video did all right I
think it got like 20 000 views but now
that you were creative even in like you
know that oh I was I was doing YouTube I
always knew I wanted to use yeah I just
didn't know what and then so when I
started doing Game Dev I was like well I
might as well try this again yeah and I
originally I tried making tutorials I
think I made one on like health bars
and I still have the videos but they're
not public and then I was like I
actually don't know much about what I'm
talking about here maybe tutorials isn't
the play I started with tutorials as
well and I knew nothing like yeah I was
like 16 and I started learning Java and
like three months later I was making
like videos on yeah 3D game and Java
it's kind of good though because you get
a different perspective like yeah I
think there's value in it because the
people teaching have just learned this
themselves so they know exactly fresh in
their mind how they how they clicked it
you know yeah so there's that but it's
like you can't do anything Advanced and
it's like I don't know one of the
reasons why I started doing that
specifically I remember was because I
was always like pretty decent at math
like in in high school yeah and so a lot
of people would ask me for help you know
and then I'd come over to them and I'd
explain stuff to them and like help them
out with their math and in doing so it
would reinforce like I'd be like
yeah that's a good point like I would
learn more about it you know I would
kind of look at it from a different
perspective I guess and so I realized
that by teaching like you learn so much
and I think that coupled with the fact
that once I had the ball rolling for
some reason those videos took off like
immediately and I mean took off is like
you know not like millions of views but
like I was getting like I don't know a
few hundred views like maybe a few
thousand views pretty much instantly and
like I'm pretty sure like since the day
I posted the first episode I was getting
like seven subscribers a day oh wow just
out of nowhere I guess search results or
something yeah but like it just
immediately started rolling so there was
already like after a few months there
was already like a few hundred people
that were subscribed to me who was like
were like tuning in every Sunday when I
release an episode and so sometimes I
like I'd be like all right well I
basically taught everything I know
what's next like I have to learn more
but then the and then I might have been
lazy but the people would be writing me
messages right being like bro where's
the next episode like why why are you
not coming out with another episode and
so I think when I was not motivated
those people were kind of almost forced
me to keep pushing through stuff I
didn't know and actually learn you know
even if I wasn't feeling like it or I
just wanted to play video games or I
wanted to do whatever so I think that
whole kind of idea of
just learning stuff fresh and then
immediately like flipping it and
teaching it like yeah of course I said a
lot of rubbish and I sort of I said a
lot of stuff that was just completely
false and like there were way better
ways of doing stuff and I didn't explain
everything but like
it's it benefited me quite quite a bit
it's funny that's what matters at the
end of the day
um so yeah there was
oh yeah the tutorials and then I was
like maybe I should do something else so
I made a game called exhausted which was
like it was like a it was weird you
played as a car and you had a certain
amount of fuel and you had to get to the
next fuel canister to carry on through
the level oh yeah so it was like a pun
like because the car got exhausted all
right yep yeah
um and then I made a devlog series on
that
three episodes I think and uh they
didn't do very well and then I did the
same but they're still up somewhere I
like they I have them yeah yeah I don't
like it or whatever yeah and then um did
the same thing for another game I was
working on called Gatling which was um
basically like a tower defense game but
right he plays a plane and there's like
waves of planes coming in and like
blimps and things and you have to defend
this Central Crystal yeah I'd like to
revisit that at some point like it was
cool and then after that that was that
was the first stint of videos and
nothing did very well and at that point
I was like I kind of want to do I want
to do higher quality stuff but less
frequently and try and you know do some
more one-off things so that's when I
made the first video that's still public
which was
sled racing from Club Penguin I turned
that into a multiplayer game oh yeah and
I've seen that video yeah honestly if I
I don't think that video would still be
up if I didn't hold so much like
sentimental value yeah just because that
was the first one that was like really
proud of man I I'm really bad like I'm
really bad at doing that like taking
down videos yeah like I've taken down a
few but there is so much garbage on my
Channel that I really probably should
clean up but like I just I don't know
why I just
yeah because everyone does that everyone
seems to do that but I'd never do that
basically I did I like I don't know
there's there's benefits and cons like
doing it but the main thing for me was
that I'd completely shifted the
direction that I wanted to take oh yeah
my YouTube channel in and like the
editing was so much higher quality than
everything else yeah that was just kind
of like this is the fresh start now well
it's kind of like in a way you wanted to
present it like a portfolio yeah
basically yeah yeah and then then I did
the C plus plus video
and then I did a couple more but like
nothing happened with those but then
this equals plus video started to go off
um and then yeah that's when I was like
right I'll do more of these so we did
the The Challenge videos with polymers
the the thousand dollar ones and stuff
they were like they did really well
which we kind of
we thought they were going to do well
um because we I remember we had like a
call where we sat down and we were like
what other niches can we apply to
gamedev like how can we change this up
because we saw like
Danny had you know kind of made his more
like entertaining and gaming videos and
we were like what what can we take from
and we were like
Mr Beast obviously yeah biggest guy like
how can we apply that so then we were
like oh we'll use money for the stakes
and like we'll try and edit it in a more
like fast-paced and like and it worked
and then we made a couple of those and
then yeah just been making games since
that's where I'm at now
and so you're yeah so you're kind of
but long longer term you still see
yourself more as a game developer right
than a YouTuber I honestly don't know
you don't know it used to look kind of
because I like the entire thing like the
fact that I can start with nothing yeah
and end up with a game and a documentary
on that game yeah yeah that entire
process like I love that yeah just
creating it all from nothing but
I think
I do enjoy the YouTube side of it more
um but it's the longevity of it I don't
think it's gonna last forever right yeah
which is kind of where I'm like
I want to transition more into
traditional game development yeah kind
of thing so that's kind of the thought
process about at the moment do you ever
feel like it's like such a saturated
environment now that it's so accessible
to make games that trying to survive as
a game developer would be difficult long
term as well so say say the YouTube as
you said Is Not Gonna Last Forever and
it goes down like does it worry you at
all that you'll be able to create and
Market games in such a saturated Market
yeah because obviously like the only
reason that
you know I'm
so eager to make this game is because
I've got an audience who are instantly
gonna play it right yeah that's such a
huge advantage and I feel like a lot of
Indie developers don't realize how
massive of a tool that actually is yeah
like just to share some numbers like I
released four Steam games last year and
every single one of them has got over
200 000 downloads yeah like and that's
they're not amazing yeah they're they're
far from it like these were things I
made in two three months that I kind of
threw together just for a video yeah and
I didn't care about the game like I
cared more about the video at the end of
it yeah so like I mean it's a backwards
way of making stuff but just based on
that like I made four
all right games and for a total of like
almost a million downloads just because
I have the audience yeah right that's
such a powerful tool
yeah really interesting to say can you
is there any way you can see on Steam I
guess what how much comes from natural
like steam suggestions versus say direct
links yeah because it'd be interesting
out of those 200 000 like how much is
directly your audience versus like maybe
if your audience gives it that push in
the beginning it's almost like the
YouTube algorithm it like spreads it to
so many people who you know in turn
brings audience to your YouTube from
Steam yeah so I have a theory for this
because I released the first one mushy
in like January last year and that came
out and it did way better than I thought
it was going to do and my theory is is
like because it's a multiplayer game
it's free like anyone who watches my
video is gonna go and be like I want to
play this now who do I place oh I've got
these friends on Discord let's let's get
them involved and then they start
playing and they're like oh this guy's
got a YouTube channel so then they go to
the YouTube channel which helps the
video yeah but it also helps the gamer
because they've shared it with their
friends and then it creates this like
back and forth effect where steam is now
pushing my YouTube videos and my YouTube
videos now pushing the steam game yeah
and it's like they're almost like
working in tandem to just grow this
thing yeah
um and it's like all I think all four of
them were on new and trending and
everything like which means that the
steam algorithm definitely played a huge
part in that because I don't think you
could even get on new and training just
through like direct yeah no well yeah I
think it has to right be somewhat real
yeah yeah because otherwise I'm sure
there'd be like bot Farms yeah exactly
because it's for that kind of thing um
but yeah no like probably it's insane
like how many YouTube channel is 100 the
best thing you can do and Tick Tock as
well like it's yeah nah like yeah I've
I've always like I guess treasured that
and then thought about that
um because I guess I've had a YouTube
channel before I really started trying
to make things yeah and so having that
initially it's like I've never not had
that so that's why like sometimes when
people are making games because they
want to be game developers yeah they
want to make YouTube videos so they want
to be game developers and then like you
know there's all these like
stressful like guides on how to Market
your game oh you should start at Twitter
early in the development and start
posting updates you should do this and
that and it's like uh like that would be
so
that would be so scary I I agree like
that that sounds horrible to me yeah
because the the other thing as well with
having a YouTube channel like a decently
successful one is like you're also like
financially covered while you're
developing right but if you're starting
from scratch and you're making a
completely new game and you've not got
that like you're you're not only you're
gonna have to find like financially
support yourself but then you're gonna
also have to market the game and it's
like that's so much more work
and uh yeah like I don't know I'd
recommend anyone make a YouTube channel
for your game like yeah it's it's the
best thing you can possibly do in the
market and I think a lot of people are
obviously a lot of people are interested
in the development of games right
because devlogs tend to do well and then
Gamers I think what's interesting as
well is that like
there are lots of you know like people
who can people who consume films people
who love movies like okay maybe people
who are really into movies like like to
see how they're made but I feel like
people who consume movies they just like
to consume movies right like people just
like to watch movies right but I feel
like a lot of Gamers like maybe past
casual gamers they like to think of
themselves as pretty technical yeah I
agree right like what's interesting is
that like who cares what game engineer
game was made in oh but it does because
Gamers will be like oh well the physics
are like that because that's the source
engine like you know people will like
lots of people who play games and
consume that kind of they have like the
surface level knowledge yeah but they
like to pretend that they know a lot
more yeah yeah and so I feel like
because of that devlog specifically
resonate really well with that crowd who
actually will play games yeah and they
like to see how games are developed
um which can work really well because if
you are making a game then turns out
people want to see how it's made yeah uh
and that is just a really good kind of
cycle vicious cycle of success no I
agree yeah yeah definitely
um yeah when you were talking about the
backwards uh how it was kind of
backwards oh backwards way of I guess
development because it's almost like the
video in a way it drives the game you're
making a game for a video yeah
um I think yeah doing things backwards
seems to be quite successful in general
because I feel like what I started doing
recently is
because I guess I realized
um how important video like the video
title and thumbnail is on YouTube
might like I would basically come up
with a video title and a thumbnail
before I made the video up and I would
still kind of have like the topic would
I still come up with a topic and be like
oh I want to make a video on this topic
but I would then be like all right well
what could it be like what would the
title be what would what would the
thumbnail be like how do I package this
information in something that's
appealing to people and then from there
I had basically structure and create a
video to kind of suit what I thought
would make a good title and thumbnail
and that just seems to do a lot better
see this this is the problem as well
like this is why it's so hard to
is so much more difficult than you'd
think to make be an indie developer on
YouTube because like from my experience
like I was oh I am kind of like fully on
the YouTube side of things rather than
like I'm more interested in that for the
most part than getting development yeah
at least right now
and uh I would I would have lists of
game ideas and I'm not picking these
game ideas based on the one that I want
to work on the most I'm picking a game
idea based on what I think is going to
do the best yeah so for example like my
Manhunt game like I was fairly confident
that that video was going to do well
before I'd even started anything on it
because I was like it's Manhunt you've
got the dream Manhunt stuff you know
most people played that game as a kid
like I'm gonna have these weird
characters like that did well in my last
game it's goofy it's multiplayer it's
free This Can't Fail yeah and then I
release the video and it did really well
and it's like you have to be in that
mindset if you and there's a lot of
people that do this like to the extreme
where they will specifically make these
like really low quality videos and like
what low quality games and then make
devlogs on them but like they're just
trying to exploit some sort of like
Nostalgia or something yeah you know
what I mean like yeah yeah like uh
resonate with an audio with like what I
said like uh for example like I don't
know something like Mario Kart or which
which I did to be fair
um or like Subway Surfers or yeah Angry
Birds or something like that where like
you the game doesn't even have to be
good this is the thing yeah if the video
is like marketed probably like this is
the problem and a lot of Indie
developers are working on games that
they're like genuinely passionate about
like their dream games and stuff and if
you you've already sent time into that
and now you want to Market this like
maybe it's not the best thing for
YouTube yeah and like if you're in that
position and then you try to Market it
like it is difficult
um yeah like it there's so many
different ways of looking at it you know
and I think as well that like that's
it's definitely not necessarily a bad
thing to have those restrictions like in
a way it's kind of like I want to make a
dream game but actually let me make
something that's a bit more suited for
something like you might look at that as
like wow why are you limiting yourself
creatively but I feel like a lot of the
times when you when you are as an artist
limited creatively you know that's where
you're forced to kind of think outside
the box and maybe even create something
a bit more original yeah you know
because you have to make it fit like a
certain format I guess and that's why
like in a way you know with game jams
that are based on particular themes I
feel like the games that do really well
in those game jams uh and not just like
you know in terms of votes and stats but
like just you know how good is this work
of art how good is this game like is it
fun are the games that adhere closer to
the themes because when you place those
restrictions on yourself like I feel
like you're forced to try and create
something that fits within that box yeah
and that can be you know something
really uh I guess special compared to
just like this is open-ended I'm gonna
make
something a bit more kind of I don't
know
Bland yeah not 100 yeah I agree with
that
and um yeah
a little little kombucha break what what
do you think about
um
like what do you think about marketing
games like aside from like you've got
YouTube right
and you can kind of somewhat rely on
that to at least give the game an
initial push but is there anything else
that you think you'll do for marketing
aside from just
uh yeah I have an idea of something that
I'd like to try
um so I made a take talks to like tick
tock's like the main focus of this
because it's so much easier to get views
on Tick Tock than YouTube because their
algorithm is just so much better like it
knows how to give people exactly what
they want to see yeah so as long as
there's an audience for your thing your
thing is gonna probably get views as
long as it's semi-good quality right so
I did um I did a few tick tocks like
they did all right like I think one one
of them got like 700 000 views or
something which is crazy because it took
me an hour to edit right and to do that
on YouTube would be you know obviously
the views are a lot less like they hold
a lot less weight yeah because it's just
people you know scrolling yeah they're
less likely to engage and actually yeah
yeah yeah definitely
um and then I did like a little Series
where I did like a game for every letter
of the alphabet once at one a day and
that I ended up getting to like G I
think yeah yeah I saw that yeah no that
was seriously dropped off my radar it's
interesting how I'm served up so much of
your content like on Twitter without
following me too maybe it's because
people have Fuller reply to you though
maybe that's it's a pretty Niche like
you know yeah like you get recommended
everything because I'm fairly sure I
follow polymers
oh wow if I don't that's like then it's
like why is this happening
[Laughter]
um so you got up to G got up to G but
yeah like I wanna see what I don't I
don't follow him as well well following
two people on a podcast I didn't
Envision doing before we started so yeah
the the idea is like okay those views
don't hold much weight right now like
how can you make them hold more weight I
guess so what I want to try and do is do
some mobile games yeah because everyone
on Tick Tock is on their phone yeah it's
average audience is a lot younger so
I just think I think that might be the
play like I want to try and just make a
mobile game Throw Some Like You know uh
replayable ads or whatever on there and
just see how well it does yeah marketing
through tick tock and I I think I think
that'll work like I think there's a huge
untapped potential there yeah
specifically for mobile games and
especially like I think you should
definitely try and make that game
specifically optimized to be a mobile
game yes like you know the controls and
everything it shouldn't just be like
some arbitrary game that let's map it to
mobile control 100 you should almost
like natively take control of the device
and optimize it for that experience
that's what I want to do like uh Sam
Hogan did a a game like stick with it it
was called it's like a rage game
um yeah Jamie pull that up
it's like a blue ball he's like got soft
buddy physics yeah and he sticks to
things and then you get an arrow that
like goes like this uh I've definitely
seen that and you have to tap at a
specific time
yeah yeah that's the game
but it's like something like that would
be perfect right yeah because it looks
cool like you've got like a yeah I got
some gameplay there you go so you just
have to tap and then
yeah and it's it's so it's so good when
there are a few controls as well it's
just one yeah yeah when it's like I feel
like sometimes again it can get so
overwhelming being like if it's when
people try to make serious games for
mobile that's what also kind of bugs me
sometimes yep because it's just like
it's just frustrating to play you know
because what like why if a game is
better played on a computer you know if
that's really the game you want to make
and it's better on like a PC or a
console like make it for that
yeah
because it's weird it's almost like
because that pretty much everyone has a
computer it's like I understand like if
you don't want to make games it's like
console exclusive because more people
will have computers most likely right
yeah but for mobile like most people
probably have a like a laptop or a phone
yeah I think it's kind of like almost
picking the best tool for the job right
if you really want to deliver this
experience then it's almost like if you
look at the game as as its own entity
yeah it's not like a PC game or a mobile
game it's a game yeah where's it this is
the experience I want to present where
would that experience best be you know
almost like an installation artwork yeah
where it's like do I project it on a
projector or do I have it on a small
little display what looks better yeah no
I I agree with that although I think uh
like a lot of uh big game companies are
starting to just pour games to mobile
just because they can and it's like some
of them work really well I think it's
because like uh like southeast Asia like
a lot of people don't have like
computers and stuff but they do have
phones
um so it's like cod mobile for example
yeah that is so fun yeah like it works
so well but a lot of them don't like
they'll just completely one-to-one Port
something and then it just doesn't seem
to work on the phone like it has to be
you you almost have to take a lot more
care with your design when you're going
for mobile just because
you've got a lot less wiggle room like
it needs to feel perfect almost
because it's such a restricted kind of
platform as well like you know it's it's
hard to do stuff well unless you have
like one of those controllers that you
can snap the phone onto and then it's
kind of okay but like even like you know
fortnite mobile like that does really
well I'm just like I'm honestly a bit
surprised that anyone would bother
playing that on a phone you know as I
say I think a lot of it is uh southeast
Asia like the the kids maybe kids who
maybe aren't even allowed like computer
time or don't have a computer who can
just kind of sneak away with a phone and
play it yeah I mean it's a huge Market I
think it's bigger than like PCM console
now mobile yeah it's it's huge yeah I
know it was growing like crazy when I
was making mobile games like a DA yeah
yeah no I that's anyway that's the plan
like I want to make something really
small and Polished and then just try and
Mark it as much of it as I can on Tick
Tock and see how far that goes yeah like
at the very least it'll be a fun
experiment yeah so
how many like what's your development
schedule like because you're doing this
full time right so how how do you set
your hours and work and stuff I'm really
bad at that actually to be honest like
um I kind of burnt myself out which is
why I'm here like I kind of wanted to
just say you know take a break from
everything to the studio Channel when
they Bend themselves down
this is the clinic I was told I was I
was told by a man in England to come
here
a guy in a Wizard's room
uh no what was I saying
well you better yourself out yeah yeah
yeah I kind of like just I don't know
like I was I was it was at the point
where I was like
I would work like 12 hours a day just
like get up just work sometimes like if
me and because obviously I'm working
with someone in Australia like I'd have
to stay up late quite a bit or he'd have
to stay up late and so it would get to
the point where I'd be on this like
two-week cycle of like my sleep schedule
would just get me progressively worse
and worse and worse but I'd still be
working the same amount of time even if
I was sleeping later and stuff yeah and
so I was kind of I need to figure out
how I'm gonna do this better to be
honest because I'm I'm terrible at it I
just work until I can't and then I rest
and that's kind of the strategy this far
I'm not very good at taking breaks and
things like it just power through yeah
to be honest so because I was going to
ask you how you balance you know your
time off I guess with I honestly like
for example like if I want to go out or
something like I'll just wait until
that's happening and then I'll just give
myself the time and like as long as I'm
not taking too much time away yeah like
I'm quite good at like spontaneously
just doing things that I want to do
rather than having a certain day every
week that I want to you know have off
because then I feel like that won't line
up with a lot like a lot of my friends
aren't as lucky to be doing what I'm
doing so they have schedules and stuff
and so it's easier to just kind of be
free with it and then whenever I need to
take breaks or yeah go and do something
like I can just do that yeah and then I
don't feel guilty about not working
enough because whenever I'm not doing
that I am working do you take weekends
off or do you just that's not any other
day it doesn't really matter yeah no
honestly
um but like I do take I do do a lot of
things during the week it's just at
different points like you know like I'll
go out for a few hours or whatever but
it's never planned right yeah I'll just
uh yeah I just play as it is yeah which
is probably not the best well I mean
you've wound up in Australia on a
burnout breaks
um definitely not the best thing so yeah
so I feel like it might actually be
better to like try and force yourself to
take you know breaks and balance it you
know yeah because like I mean I I used
to do that as well I basically used to
just in all my spare time I would kind
of just like be like all right I want to
work on Hazel All back when I went to
the EA like you know I'd come home and
work on like this whole series videos
um and like it was always kind of like
because work for me was fun so therefore
it's like if I have some spare time I
want to do some programming right I want
to do some and I've got like I have
other interests as well but like it
still kind of like keeps coming back to
this I guess most of the time and so
that kind of also wasn't the best
because it would mean that like
like I find that every time I go on a
holiday somewhere and I'm forced to not
touch anything I'm just itching to get
back at it and I think most people who
else kind of where I'm at now I like
that yeah yeah I mean this was kind of a
business trip for you did some you
probably did some Devin Brisbane no no
actually oh okay I've not touched the
line of code for like a month great it's
been good that wasn't the original plan
but then I got over here and I was kind
of like yeah screw everything like I'm
having a I was like I tried to try to
work and like I tried to start on this
mobile thing and I was just like
no I need I need time like I because
it's like I also didn't want to waste
the trip right like I've flown halfway
across the world yeah but yeah no flying
halfway across the world to basically do
what you could have done at home yeah
it's not it's not the not the play
um
but yeah no it's uh yeah
what actually ended up happening for me
is like I guess you know once I got into
a relationship and I got married like
I guess I'm not just single anymore
which means that I don't really get to
100 choose how I spend my time right and
so like my wife will obviously now that
I have a daughter like you know I can't
really work weekends that's not really
fair to them and so it's a in a way it's
like I'm forced to obviously balance my
time with that it's like conscious like
I can't just work 24 7. and that's good
because like I feel like if I was like
all alone and I was single and I would
just like you know my friends didn't
want to do anything or whatever yeah
then it's like what would I do like well
what else would I do like maybe I'll
play some music or go out on a hike or
do something kind of not decided 100
right when I get back to it like because
I was in a relationship last year and it
was it was good because whenever I was
taking a break like we were spending
time together so it's like yeah you're
almost forced into taking these breaks
like having something else there to get
you out of it all is great
um like recently for me that's been rock
climbing like just going and getting
better at rock climbing like I love
doing it it's it's great and so having
another thing you can do definitely
helps yeah uh to alleviate the stress
and like actually you know
force you to take breaks if you are
naturally the sort of person that will
just keep going
I think you definitely need something
like that or the gym or anything like
that you know yeah I I go to the gym
quite often like I usually go there's
it's just like down the road from the
office yeah like usually around lunch
like I'll you know have like a nice kind
of breakfast to feel me out for that and
then a few hours after breakfast I'll go
to the gym for like an hour or so yeah
and like I mean last week I did it
literally every day
um and it's just such a good like way to
just completely it's almost like I come
back and it's like a new day you know
because I'll go to the gym and like you
know have a a nice workout and then
like I'm not sure if this is the best
thing to do after a workout but I always
end my workout with a cold shower right
and I've started kind of doing cold
showers in the morning sometimes also
it's getting colder they're also kind of
yeah but the it's just like oh it just
completely snaps you out of it and I'll
have a cold shower at the entire like
the entire shower will be cold after my
workout
um and it just gets me into like this
almost survival mode and like I feel
like I get back to the office and I'm
just like super focused and I'm like
it's like it's like a new day you know
it's like that's it because yeah before
that I feel like I used to have this
thing where after lunch you know I'd
kind of just be
a little bit done yeah with the day and
I'll be like I'll just do that tomorrow
you know I'll just like whatever like
I'll just like I don't want to film
anything because I'm not motivated so it
won't be as energetic it won't be as
engaging I'll just do it tomorrow but
this is like making two days in one and
it's it's really cool I think it's good
as well because like what I've noticed
with rock climbing is because I'm in
like a place and I'm using my brain but
it's not looking at a screen which is
very rare nowadays you know like to
actually be actively thinking but you're
not looking at a screen yeah you walk
out there and you feel so good yeah same
with the gym like just you you've spent
so much time just like doing something
else that's productive and you feel
great about yourself and that helps as
well to not get burnt out because you
know you come back into it and you
you're in a good mood so yeah takes
longer yeah now it's really it's really
important to balance work and I think
that like especially when you're working
on large projects you know like if
you're working on a game that is
obviously like more than maybe a small
two three month game
um you know I'm working on Hazel which
is you know quite a large game engine
and it there's like it's really easy to
get overwhelmed yeah and like I think
that when you're a little bit when
you're when you're constantly active and
you're working on something like you can
kind of
you it's almost like you get I don't
know like if you get like tunnel vision
or what the best way to phrase this is
but you get sucked into that world and
it's almost like you become
a small ant just like crawling around
the code and you're like I'm just
surrounded by like code yeah it's
everywhere like I I'm losing I feel like
it feels like I'm losing a grasp on how
everything is fitting together and
working like will this even work in the
end like everybody just been refactoring
this code for no reason and trying to
improve it like the stats really right
was I sure about the timings like is
this really going to come together in
the end and I feel like you know and
then you start thinking like oh my life
is just like this is just code this is
just like an engine this is gonna I'm
never gonna have these features like I'm
never gonna be able to finish this like
I can't even oh but then there's that
that I have to do after I do this thing
like it's so easy to just get sucked
into that world and that's all that
exists almost you know and you just get
so overwhelmed but I feel like when you
step back from that and you force
yourself just physically force yourself
for time like to to get time to pass
just like I don't know go watch a clock
or something but just do something that
will just alleviate the pressure from
your brain and let you just clear it I
feel like
well for me at least it's almost like my
mood starts improving and I'm kind of
like ah this isn't that bad like I'll
just you know I was able to do this last
year like I'll just work through it you
know slowly because yeah I guess in a
way it's like you're zooming out this is
kind of a good way to look at it I think
the more you actively work it's like
you're you've got your camera yeah and
you're just zooming in you just got your
finger on that little zoom button like
when I want like a Handycam like a
camcorder you're just on the zoom button
a little bit it's just like zooming
zooming zooming zooming zooming in and
then when you take a break especially
like not just like a break to I don't
know have lunch but like a day 24 hours
or more 48 hours off you know that's
like you zooming out yeah and then so
you kind of zoom out and you kind of
just like see the big picture of like
how the pieces fit together and then
when you start working on it again
zooming in a little bit that's a good
way of putting it um and I that's why
it's so important to kind of zoom out to
see kind of because I feel like when
you're just an employee working in a big
software team you have someone who is
constantly zoomed out you have like a
development director or a producer
um or even a technical director who
oversees like the whole project yeah and
they they are responsible to make sure
that everyone is doing stuff on time and
that the pieces are going to fit
together yeah but when you do the job of
a software engineer who might be working
on an intricate system and also that
management yeah you have to ping pong
between them and if you don't if you're
always a software engineer then zooming
out so that you can see the whole
project and direct it and also be sure
that it is actually going to finish one
day yeah you know or at least get to an
uh like a an appropriate Milestone like
that ping-pong ping-ponging between
those two like is just so important and
you can't get that if you don't take
breaks yeah from doing that one job no
that's a really good way of playing so
yeah like I think that's that's super
important so that's what you should do
when you get back to you yeah no force
yourself to have a weekend or even one
day a week just do nothing yeah
no I do need to get better at that
definitely
what's your thoughts on uh AI within
Game Dev oh
um
I think that like
I was always a bit skeptical of AI being
that useful like people were worried
that it would take over jobs but I've
been using it for like the last month or
so just playing around with it I haven't
done anything serious with it I've been
showing like stuff to like Tim and Peter
and like it's pretty wild like you know
I mean with something like you know
Dolly getting it to generate images for
you
it almost removes the need for a concept
artist
yeah like I was just thinking about how
nice it would be like sometimes I I've
asked him in the past like hey be nice
to put together some concept art for our
game or whatever and like obviously big
studios big Productions they have a team
of concept artists
um and that's really useful because you
basically tell the concept artist this
is what I want it to look like add these
things and it's like if you feed that
into an AI you can it's getting to the
point where you can basically get the
same result yeah um and it's just so
cool for like
you know previews and just like
pre-production just being able to play
with a look and play with like a
direction and be like what would this
look like you know and that's just like
obviously that's just an example like
you know there's like chat gbt and being
able to be like I need some game ideas
man please help me out you know like I
need a game this needs to happen that
needs to happen I'm missing a unique
twist give me one see I think this is
this is where it starts to get a little
bit dangerous so because I had this
exact experience probably like two weeks
ago where I was just like I couldn't
think of any ideas for this mobile game
and so I was like all right I lost track
of GPT
and so I ask a very vague question like
uh give me five games within you know
that work with this device and whatever
and it did and then I started to refine
my search a little bit more and like
give it more parameters to work with and
more restrictions and it gave me a list
of five really good ideas yeah but I
didn't I didn't do anything with those
ideas and I feel like if you if you rely
on that like it's gonna I know I would
get to the point where I wouldn't be
able to do anything without it yeah it's
it would become this like extension of
me which is such a scary thought yeah
and I don't know how to navigate that
it's like
do I fully Embrace this and be like okay
well so what like I prompted it it's my
idea whatever or do you try and you know
distance yourself a little bit so you
don't fully lose all of that yeah
because that's that's so scary to me
like just how easily I can see myself
becoming so reliant on it yeah
but is that even a bad thing like well I
like I I think that it definitely can be
because at the end of the day
it's like what is an extension of you as
you said it's really it's an extension
of your brain it's like I don't want to
do the thinking like do the thinking for
me come up with ideas for me yeah you
know and I mean on one hand it's good
because obviously you get a fresh
perspective you know it's not like even
if you spent an hour thinking of a game
idea you just don't have as much
knowledge you know as that AI so
therefore you'd never be able to come up
with let's just say this idea
um I think the best way to approach it
or how I'm gonna personally approach it
is to try and come up with my own ideas
and then use AI to enhance that yeah so
like if I have an idea for a mobile game
I'll say okay this is my idea but I need
like a couple of obstacles could you
give me someone explain why they would
be beneficial to like like what what
value would they add to the game right
and then listen to what it has to say
like that for me is like a genuine okay
like fair enough use for AI but I feel
like if if I was using it for everything
like what what art style should I use
what game mechanics should be in this
game like and just everything and then
every time I have a problem I'm then
getting AI to solve this thing yeah it
gets to the point where it's like
what am I actually doing
but I'm just a prompt engineer at that
point
yeah I don't think it's like I would
like to not use it for ideas and like I
basically for like I would I would
prefer to use it for technical things
it's like for example there's one that I
came across recently that can generate
materials for you so you can give it a
prompt and it'll generate like a full
PBR material set for you that's awesome
like Albedo normal roughness metalness
like here you go of whatever you do like
a tax prompt and you can be like I want
some I don't know like a a tile that is
red and is rough and is you know has the
Cherno logo on it I don't know like and
it will like generate it for you and
like that's kind of cool and that's
useful and it almost replaces or
enhances something an artist will be
able to do because it's not like you
know it's not magical you're not just
gonna get a texture you're like yep
that's slap it in the game that looks
perfect that's exactly what I wanted it
to look like yeah you're probably still
going to need to tweak it or play with
prompt or fit it back in but for like
creativity you know for like ideas for
stuff that like really is less Technical
and more human
I feel like it would be a bad idea to
rely too heavily on that because then
like you know it's kind of like
imperfections you know like if we talk
about music for a second like
auto-tune's very prevalent and pretty
much everyone uses it but if it's like
but there's also something organic about
imperfections and music like if you
don't you know record one guitar note at
a time and then sequence it so the
timing is perfect and it's just it's
like the note sounds Flawless and
everything's great and you just layer it
like you know you sequence it perfectly
like if you just record a guitar tag
naturally there's something organic
about it that I think people really like
it doesn't sound as robotic right and
same with like pitch like being slightly
like a few cents off or whatever like it
just kind of you know people even
sometimes detune things you know
especially if they like pan it left and
right and make it a bit wider then
they'll detune it by a few cents just to
get that imperfection because it
actually ends up sounding bigger and
better and I think that like if you if
you start to tune everything up and
tighten things and you make kit like
with ideas you make it less organic then
I think it becomes a lot more like
robotic in a way and it takes it will
kind of take the soul away from it even
though it's based off of a
conglomeration of like other game ideas
that have made it there's still
something like natural I think an
imperfect about the way that humans
think which resonates better you know
like with humans see I wanna I wanna be
on your side on that but I also like
that's like the number one like defense
for it not taking over and not doing
everything for us is that we have
something special yeah but for how long
okay how long is it until it can
replicate that well because obviously
you can replicate imperfections yeah as
well that's the problem that yeah but
it's weird because like again it's so
new in this field but I just know that
like
like I just don't you know to bring it
back to music and like auditory and like
I just don't know if that like because
you can obviously tell the plug the
water stream plugins to be less perfect
yeah but it's not the same no like it
just doesn't work right like as well
like you can still kind of you can
either tell or it just doesn't sound as
good okay um and like and it can add
vibrato and stuff and it can make it
like so it's not like a robotic clean
note which no one really ever sings but
it's still just like not as appealing
well it's a good point because like you
can you can like compare it to video
games right like if you have someone who
knows what they're doing with music and
they're applying the auto tune in a way
that is you know good and it adds to the
song like it's gonna sound great but if
you've got someone who knows nothing
about music and they're relying 100 on
autotune and then that's all that
they're doing like it is gonna sound
wrong and it's the same thing with games
like if you know someone like us that
kind of knows what they're doing like
uses AI to enhance what we're already
doing then it's going to be beneficial
to us and like we're gonna know how to
use it in the correct way yeah but there
is the danger of like new developers who
are relying 100 on this tool you know
yeah and so we're going to start getting
games that are like decent people are
already flipping Unity assets games you
know yeah you can steam like there's so
much stuff like you AI can easily
replicate like mobile games or like
super simple stuff like and we're gonna
get that if just these hundreds and
hundreds of games that no one's actually
touched I wonder if we'll see branding
in the future being like this was 100
made by humans like this is a AI does
not contain traces of AI yeah do you
reckon people will only consumers human
media like they won't they won't
acknowledge the AI like on Netflix you
can filter it by like no idea it's like
being vegan like you just you do like a
car like an underground cult that just
has like vanilla media like it was
actually 100 made by humans or whatever
but many people thought like that about
computer like you know when digital took
over analog maybe there was there was
probably like a you know a cult
following of like just analog only I
just think this is like it's
incomparable to anything like it's nice
it's so powerful yeah but I think there
was a time in history when we didn't
have calculators right and then
calculators were introduce and all of a
sudden you don't need to no longer
version anymore because five clicks or
one when you have your answer I think
the the biggest difference is like if
you try and compare it to anything like
you've still got this like narrow view
like with that like it's 100 to do with
math and numbers and whatever this thing
can do anything
this can enhance any aspect of all of
our Lives you know like it's well that's
different it's like having a really
intelligent person with you all the time
that can do things instantly yeah
it's like a it's like a superpower yeah
um but luckily you know we are we as in
me and I guess my team are really bad at
using existing tools to our benefit you
know such as engines so I feel like if
anything will be okay like we won't you
we'll probably be like I'm gonna do it
myself yeah I don't want to use it AI
yeah
um nah but yeah like I think I think
it's really important to try and maybe
not use it for uh creative things but
like again for to bring it back to
technical things like
um I'm working on a video right now uh
like with C plus plus and Ai and it's
just interesting because like because I
just started playing around with chat
GPT and I was like I saw someone uh
getting it to like write blender scripts
oh yeah so like if you want to you know
add some functionality to like scale up
scale down like a bunch of entities or
what meshes and blender you could write
that script in python or you could just
be ask for what you wanted it does it
instantly and it's obviously a lot
quicker and Bug like less bugs and stuff
and I was like I wonder how much how
good this is for C plus plus so I'm like
all right write me like a resizable
array yeah and it wrote me a you know
resizable array
that I think dealt with integers and
then I was like uh all right let's make
this templated so I can use it like with
any type and it did it and then I'm like
add some comments that like explains
what it does and it added comments to
every line of code that explains it and
like I'm just thinking I'm like
the thing is and I read through the code
and and I'm like
this is good because it it's like
everyone who goes through like writing
and dynamic array for the first time
usually makes like if there's a high
probability they'll make certain
mistakes yeah and obviously the AR
hasn't done that like there's no memory
leaks it does exactly what it needs the
gotchas are kind of ironed out right
like they're not there yeah you know
they've handled cases correctly and I'm
just thinking like you know sometimes
when humans write code it's so difficult
to think through a certain logic kind of
problems and also what's really
important for programming is being aware
of context like all the time and the
bigger the project you work on the more
context you need to retain in your brain
when working on any given system because
like Suddenly It's like for a game
engine you need to know how it functions
with other systems and like you know
suddenly oh it's a big game engine is it
is the support the Nintendo switch and
Xbox and Playstation oh well actually
the file system access is different on
those platforms so this part really
isn't going to be feasible like you have
to keep keep you have to keep stuff at
the back of your head and that the size
of what you need to maintain in your
memory you know gross yeah but an AI has
no problem with that and I and AI can
write some code that it ensures handles
every case and is compatible with
absolutely everything and it's also the
optimal version because it's learned
from all these other examples crazy like
that that becomes really beneficial and
I think that in a way like I don't think
it'll replace programmers but in the
same way that like you know we have an
IDE that helps us out and the compiler
that tells us error messages versus just
trying to run a program and it crashes
you know like it will become probably a
tool yeah that is just so easy to be
like I don't know I need to normalize a
matrix like why would I have to look up
because I have to look at it's not like
I'm gonna write that from scratch yeah
I'm going to Google that and then find
like some existing code from another
library that will normalize a matrix if
I if I'm not using an existing library
but why not just be like hey AI I have a
4x3 matrix or whatever I want to
normalize it you know there's my code
beautiful it would be cool to have like
it built into an IDE and it hasn't it
has some sort of understanding of what
you're trying to do it kind of it is in
a way isn't isn't that GitHub co-pilot
in Visual Studio code I think I think it
is uh but it's like what I'm trying to
say is like if it has if it just scans
through all of your yeah and it
genuinely understands what you're trying
to build yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
you start to do stuff and then it it can
tell you like just as a reminder you've
already done this in this place or like
this might break this certain thing yeah
like just telling you if that's like a
static analyzer yeah like static
analyzers will go through but they don't
really have contacts they look at very
narrow Scopes as far as I'm aware
um and like they'll kind of just expand
macros and do things within one function
but they obviously can't understand your
whole system as a whole and what's
coming is yeah I could do that
that would be a kill at all that would
be awesome for like billions but at the
same time why doesn't the AI just do it
itself then
at that point do everything yeah because
well because it's it doesn't like it's
gonna have its own mind so it's not
gonna know what to build like if an like
you're gonna you're gonna still have to
tell it you're going to want to build
this product yeah but then it builds the
whole product as we're saying yeah yeah
there's no reason why not which is so
scary really I mean you're gonna want
like to feed in stuff to it but just in
in English like for example my customer
wants these features add them how crazy
is that if I could get it to like add
undo redo to Hazel really quickly you
should do that that'd be a cool video
oh yeah maybe I should does work in
Visual Studio yeah I should make a video
that's like I'm trying to add a feature
to Hazel yeah but I can only use AI I
can't manually type yeah so even if
there's like one little tweak I have to
make no I have to tell the AI to fix
that right that would be a cool video
idea
yeah but the thing is it seems like
programmers are eventually just gonna
become as I said prompt Engineers yeah
like the people who really know how to
design
like the design is the thing I think we
will probably still do for the longest
time I don't think forever yeah but
there'll be a point where we are the
designers and we've effectively we can
just type what we want and it just it it
builds it but like I think it's really
cool because it you know yeah of course
you could look at that as a negative
thing but the thing is what's
interesting is that I enjoy programming
obviously but I don't I don't really
think of myself as a programmer like I
definitely introduced myself as a
software engineer programmer yeah but I
don't really think of myself as a
programmer like at the end of the day
I'm building a game engine that lets us
make games and I write code y because
that's what needs to happen for me to
tell the computer what to do right so
but again obviously I do enjoy that part
of it like it is fun to me but that
being said like if I suddenly if that's
replaced by Ai and I become a prompt
engineer yeah I'm still at the end of
the day like now using AI instead of my
own you know Hands-On knowledge more of
a game engine designer it's what you're
saying then kind of like well I guess
like I'm using it as a tool yeah you
know to achieve something and I guess
you know if I really had to expand
everything into the long form I guess
what I'm trying to do is I want to be
able to make like 3D interactive
experiences you know games basically I
want to make that like that is my form
of art right to tell like stories and to
create experiences right right so you
know and then what I do is I've chosen a
somewhat unique path of not using an
existing game engine but that's just my
method you know as an artist that's just
my that's what I've chosen to do people
use different mediums you know people
can use Canvas OR oil or watercolor yeah
you know to create paintings or whatever
maybe it's the game at the end of the
day a digital artwork yeah it's but it's
just I've chosen the medium of just C
plus plus let's build the technology to
render and create this game myself you
know but I I guess this got a bit
long-winded but what I was trying to say
was basically that like if I were to
become a prompt engineer yeah then in a
way that's like okay well what have I
done I've taken out all of the hours
that I spent trying to write code that
was that did the right thing that I
wanted to achieve I've taken that out of
the puzzle so that now I can focus on
yeah the design and focus on like well
what do I actually want this game engine
to do now how like what do I like what
is the experience I want to provide to
game developers using my engine and like
my team using Hazel to make the game
that we're trying to make and how do I
kind of like you know I it's like I've
taken that out so I have all this free
time now to actually think about other
problems that I want to solve the thing
is is that in a way actually one more
thing in a way it's like expanding your
team because if I suddenly stumbled upon
millions of dollars and let's just say I
expanded Hazel the Hazel team and Studio
Cherno now it's a thousand people yeah
right in a way supposing I also hired
some really top tier managers who could
make those people work together really
well I've in a way it's almost like I
have a bit of an AI because what have I
done like I've outsourced the hours that
I spend now and now people can do it so
quickly that like what used to take me
months can maybe take a team a week
right and so now I get what I want
quicker so that means I can ask for more
I guess is my point right with AI you
can ask for more you can expand your
scope and Achieve things that you just
wouldn't have had the resources to do
previously
the other thing though is by doing that
like you've set the
level of knowledge needed to create
something so much lower than it actually
is right yeah because which is what like
Unity did except for games like because
most of your like you've obviously sank
a lot of time into like learning about
all of this stuff right but a majority
of that will have been learning how to
program so effectively all that time and
knowledge that you have in that area is
now almost Irrelevant in a way if you
know what I mean because
all that you really need to know now is
how do I how do the parts of the game
engine interact like how do I make this
right and so you've so you've now set
the bar for entry so much lower that
you're also going to have so many more
people doing it you know like that's the
scary thing about that yeah is that yeah
okay it does make up like it makes my
job easier but now what makes me stand
out
you know yes that's the scary thing well
I guess that's true because I feel like
I feel like
yeah it's really interesting because I
don't know like it's like if athletes
like if can let's just say tennis
players were suddenly replaced by AI
then it's like the fact that someone
doesn't have to have the natural talent
to and also the hard work and dedication
to be able to become a professional
tennis player and be you know I'm going
to work harder than that person or I
have better genetics than that person
like I'm going to be better than that
person that's something that that person
has to strive for but if they just get
replaced with AI and let's just say you
could ask an AI to create a tennis
player for you then you'd be like all
right I want the perfect tennis player
done so then you have two perfect tennis
players they're playing against each
other they're they know everything they
can see the future or whatever they're
like Jedi with the force or whatever
they can see stuff before it happens
like and you get a very boring game so
like it it's like the skills and at that
point obviously if tennis was replaced
by AI yeah it would kind of be useless
you mentioned that it's like the first
time I've heard something I've been like
oh you probably couldn't replace that
because I feel like the difference
between that and like a movie for
example is I feel like when people go to
the movies to watch something they don't
really care about how it was made they
don't care about the actors that much
like it's more is this going to give me
a good time and like if the movie's good
then it does but with tennis it's like
you don't I feel like you don't go to
watch a bully and hit by a rocket you go
like it's it's intense because you have
like uh you might have an emotional
connection to one of the players
repression and the hard work and the
hard work but yeah you're 100 right
there like yeah it's interesting yeah
and so so I think in a way if
programming suddenly became very powered
by AI then anyone of course could ask
for anything and get that let's just say
every it just magically works perfectly
then suddenly it's like well a lot of
people are gonna ask for the same thing
yeah and so and suddenly it doesn't
matter how many resources or how
talented the people building this are
because it's the AI building it and it's
probably the same AI built yeah so you'd
get a lot of like individual things I
think it almost reminds me a little bit
of like when Unity like kind of came out
with like their Marketplace and like the
asset store and then like there were
steam would just pop up with clones of
like games that maybe were basically
just from the asset store maybe
rebranded a little bit and you started
getting all these Unity games and there
was also for a long time I don't know if
this is still around but like there was
always like people could just tell games
were made with unity because of the way
they looked like this just looks like
Unity you know and it's kind of like I
feel like with AI as well you there
would be a with low effort AI because
with unity of course you put enough time
into it no one could ever tell that was
made with unity like Hollow Knight for
example that might as well have been
made with anything yeah that didn't look
nothing like anything because every
pixel of that game is basically driven
by arts and by like hand almost you know
like they use a bit of like 2D lighting
or they layer it in 3D space or whatever
but like that could have been done in
any tool like but if you if it's low
effort it's like it has unity written
all over it and so I think that like
yeah with AI as well like you know stuff
that is
but but the problem is it's different
because it is an intelligence yeah you
could be like make it like this but make
it unique yeah yeah make it look like in
fact here's my whole portfolio this is
my style AI make something that looks
like I made it and then you're done and
then you're done
no it's pretty scary it's so scary but
again like are you sure because the
problem with with AI is that I feel like
when people talk about AI like we are
right now we could just be resorting
back to being children and just
imagining like using our imagination
like is this really
possible and is it really where we're at
right now or are we just envisaging like
the perfect case yeah we definitely are
doing that I think but what you've also
got to remember is like how quickly this
thing's gonna snowball
like even if you look at how fast like
we as a species of just like done things
in the last like 20 years 20 years ago
you didn't have the iPhone like all the
computers were like
really slow they couldn't do they
couldn't do you know what we're doing
today yeah like the amount of Technology
like with VR all this stuff has happened
in 20 years and now
AI has obviously always been one of
those things that we knew was coming but
it's it's in the future like we're never
gonna see whatever yeah but now we're
here and we've got something that is
genuinely like doing amazing things that
you didn't think would be possible now
and it's like in a year's time What's it
gonna look like I just think we're too
like we're in over our heads like it's
gonna go so quick
and that perfect case will come yeah
well just just when
anyway I feel like we could talk about
this for we definitely could hours
I think as well that like um
you know people of like Elon Musk for
example are wrestling about like the
fact you know him I think on The Joe
Rogan podcast like in 2018 he was
calling for like regulation I think for
this yeah Jamie Tim
um he he was like and this was in the
news recently like I don't know Elon
Musk like yeah they did a petition on AI
recognition yeah sure uh
he's long yeah like he yeah AI pause say
that first the
uh the one below
yeah click on that
um yeah like he he uh he's called for a
pause like I think he wanted everyone to
take six months off research yeah
um to just kind of chill out for a bit
Yeah like guys we need to think this
through we need to regulate it like it
that needs to capture the world huh
before it takes over the world like it's
crazy because this is the problem like
when a new technology emerges it doesn't
the regulation can't keep up with it
because it takes so long to regulate
anything it takes so long to pass laws
pass bills whatever it's like we've not
had anything
of this sort of danger go through that
process yet yeah but if they try and
regulate it it's going to take too long
because it's going to develop way too
quickly yeah and I think I think he was
saying he's like anything beyond gpt4
needs to stop just give us six months
let's figure out what we're gonna do
yeah and then we'll do this carefully
which is very true like I I 100 am on
board with that like that's yeah well
that's scary like do you think that it
will take over the world one day like do
you think that I honestly have no idea
this is a danger to the human race
I think I don't know if it proposes a
danger it's like I think we're the only
reason we're even here this is getting
existential now for it I guess about
getting development
I think
eventually no matter what path we talk
like with our intelligence what we were
going to do is raise a new set of things
that is much smarter than us I think
that was always destined to happen no
matter what we do like we're gonna reach
a limit where well I mean human race is
I guess evolved and gotten smarter right
yeah but like we also like look at the
amount of machines and things we we
already rely on like eventually we're
gonna is that a real headline what was
that San Francisco reverses plans to
allow police robots to kill suspects oh
yeah
the robots are making the decisions
yeah that's insane Is that real what's
the site The Verge yeah
but I've heard about this where police
uh were gonna like have robot squads
that would essentially go in they can't
get hurt you know like they can't get
killed in action but they can kill but
they can kill no but like surely I
wouldn't say someone's making the
decision behind them hey is all these
are tranquilizer or something I don't
know
you're like shooting to kill from a
robot well if you imagine something in
San Francisco that's I've probably got a
GDC but I guess not not anymore
in 2016 Police use the bomb disposal
robot to kill an individual her truck
and killed five police officers but
they're controlling the robot right yeah
that one was that's like a drone then
yeah that's not yeah that's that's all
right I will actually go up oh it's
allowed to allow police robots to kill
suspects but I guess robots could just
be controlled by humans not AI That's a
big difference yeah I just interpreted
it wrong I think yeah no that would be
crazy just like a self just decides to
be like well this human is not uh they
just they're just driving around the
street just like it doesn't meet the
metric or allowing it to live so I'll
shoot him that's crazy that's insane
I wonder if like China is putting
putting together
a little something they've got North
Korea have you seen like is is Tick Tock
is like because all of the Chinese
companies are like subsidized by the
Chinese government yeah yeah that have
you seen Tick Tock in China
it's like a completely different app not
really they have so yeah it trains them
doesn't it it shows them educational
content it's yeah it's so much better
for you but also like they've they've
recently like the the parent company
bite dance have basically just been like
every time a new AI startup comes about
they're just buying them they have so
much money and so they've got all of
this technology like
um
that one of the crazy things is like
they have like skin lightening
technology because it's seen as
beautiful there right so like they
detect like skin in the photos and they
artificially boost the like the
whiteness right yeah and like it's all
these things to make uh people like want
to post more because they're they're
getting more like the way they're
looking yeah they look better like they
have so much data and training and stuff
like they're effectively just an AI
company you know yeah and it's what are
they doing behind the scenes like yeah
you know
no that's anyway yeah I've been always I
don't know I don't have Tick Tock and
I've
been kind of hesitant about it you
shouldn't get it like but you've been
talking about no posting is fine
posting's fine okay right I think
consuming yeah and I think I'm all right
because education like allegations or
whatever it's 2023 yeah you can't get
away from that like I mean I guess
that's true but it but I guess the
difference is people are scared because
it's China Gathering these this
information wasn't it it was banned in I
think some schools banded but also I
think some countries have possibly
banned it I think the US have stopped
I've banned it now the US genuinely yeah
Tick Tock yeah completely
look if they haven't they're closer
doing it yeah India
as Bandit Germany
I think France
as of April 2023 the app has been banned
by federal MPS so federal employees and
set in place can't use it but only 34
out of 50 states so not everywhere but
like if you think about it isn't Tick
Tock such a good way to learn basically
everything about a culture and a country
like because they put you post
everything if you could gather like
let's just say what like everyone in the
US is posting on tick tock feed that
through some kind of AI engine and use
that as learning data for that to
basically learn the habits of just
Americans probably like you basically
know everything and you could even ask
the AI hey what's their weak spot like
yeah hypothetically if I was to uh
invade what would I do that's crazy
yeah it's just too there's I don't know
I don't have it on my phone just because
it's too addicting and I feel like my
attention span just gets worse whenever
I have it on my phone yeah so I tried to
stay away from it like consuming it
um which is ironic because I'm I'm
posting content for it oh yeah but if
you maybe if you use it strictly for
business yeah I feel like I'm I'm but is
that the way to do it because I feel
like tick tock's so natural and organic
that if you're using it for Strictly
Business use it's almost like it does
it's not genuine you know what I mean I
don't care about the consumption though
like I'm more just like you don't have
to consume it but I guess what I mean is
like it should be more chill if it's
overly produced content maybe I'm wrong
but I just feel like it's almost like
what was that app oh I see what you're
saying yeah unless you take oh it was
the Casey neistat app what was that
called Vine no no no
um
would be
oh I do know what you're talking about
actually I mean
uh beam right yeah beam b-e-m-e I think
that was something about like it just
like takes a photo but you're not
allowed to see it or something I don't
remember
anyway yeah what does it do Tim
um what's this like feature and unique
feature I guess
design is an alternative to highly
edited content found in social media the
app enables users to produce unedited
two to eight second videos which are
immediately uploaded and shared with
their users
without the ability yeah see that was
kind of yeah
I think he's solid but be real you can
see the photo and you can retake it yeah
just
I think so be real yeah be real yeah
that one's like you take I've heard of
that you take a photo from the front and
the back camera that yeah yeah and you
have to do it at a certain point in the
day like it it prompts you so you get
told at like 6 p.m like take a photo now
and you have 60 seconds to like get your
phone out and do it honey
so it just otherwise the water just
skips the day and you know yeah yeah so
like that when you scroll through your
friends it's like what were they doing
like and you can't fake it you can't be
somewhere yeah yeah yeah that no that's
that's kind of cool as well but yeah
with beam like it yeah specifically like
it didn't allow you to do
um
you know you can't edit and you can't
like even see what you're filming so
it's kind of like I guess it's an effort
to make it more genuine unless play the
opposite of tick tock Yeah well yeah I
guess tick tock's not like that but I I
guess I just saw it as a less no but I
know that people obviously produce
really highly it's like YouTube shots oh
you're saying like it should be lower
quality yeah I almost thought it should
be more of a social connection with
people but I think I'm wrong it depends
because because I know that people do
over produce stuff for it as well I
think it started out like that like but
because everybody's on it now like yeah
it was a limit see is it 60 seconds
I know they changed that it used to be
60 seconds but now that you can upload
like any length um
but I think most of them are still quite
short one hour code review Tick Tock you
fully could
you can do anything on there now you can
do live streams and everything that's
crazy yeah
yeah pretty scary I am all right you
wanna wrap this up yeah
um give some social where where can
people find you follow you what are you
promoting uh yeah wishlist go Pogo on
Steam uh And subscribe to bhaji on
YouTube and links will be in the
description below for everyone all right
thanks for doing this yes hope you
enjoyed Australia and uh see you next
time everyone goodbye
awesome
oh do you guys have a toilet here yes